let's get into some happy thoughts if
you're a cleveland browns fan i've got a
niece miles she's a huge cleveland
browns fan and she is on pins and
needles over the possibility
that jj watt
could join the cleveland browns the news
came today from mary kay cabot of the
cleveland plain dealer that what is
seriously considering the browns now
my first thought when i saw that is
that's jj's way of getting some of the
teams he's truly interested in to step
up by saying i'm about to sign with one
of them if one of you who really
are on my list of teams really want to
get this done don't wait for the salary
cap to be set let's go ahead and do this
but the browns have that luxury because
they have so much cap space they could
do this they could do it without waiting
for the cap to be set miles and maybe if
watt wants some certainty he decides not
to wait until march 17 decides to pull
the trigger now if no one else wants to
step up join a team that's on the rise
join a team that's in his brother's
division both brothers derek and tj
playing for the steelers i'd be
fascinated by the possibility of j.j
water on the browns especially when he's
got two brothers on the steelers
yes and you know what i'll tell you what
mike and the reason i've got the browns
helmet behind me is because i'm a
cleveland native but all this makes me
think is well maybe the browns isn't the
browns anymore juju smith schuster
because when you have somebody like jj
watt who is you know
seriously considering signing with the
browns this is actually something and oh
my gosh look at that look at that 99 oh
my goodness an orange and brown and
white look it's not something that you
would ever expect for the browns that
somebody of jj watts caliber could
seriously consider going to cleveland
and that it actually could be taken
seriously because in years past if some
free agent wanted to say oh yeah i'm
seriously considering going to cleveland
the rest of the league would be like all
right we'll enjoy football siberia
that's not what this is anymore so if
you're the pittsburgh steelers and
that's if that's where jj watt really
wants to go then yes signing with
cleveland is an actual threat because it
says to pittsburgh not only am i not
going to sign with you but i'm going to
sign with somebody in your division so
if you actually want me you better step
it up right now
it reminds me in a weird sort of way
and this actually may have happened
before you were even born this is going
to be very depressing when i figure out
this timeline miles but it reminds me of
reggie white going to green bay to a
lesser extent because jj watt is not in
his prime jj watt is not the player
reggie white was that's not a slight not
many guys are or ever will be the player
that reggie white was but when reggie
white picked the green bay packers that
gave the packers a far different feel
and they were a team that had been in
the wilderness in the 20 years after
vince lombardi
they started in the late 80s to be
relevant again with dawn mikowski and
they were just moving toward being a
team that should be reckoned with and
then reggie white shows up and the
perception changed the reality changed
again what's not going to have the same
impact on the browns that white would
have on the packers but from the
standpoint of the browns actually being
a serious player for jj watt it feels a
little like green bay packers reggie
white light now please tell me that you
were alive when reggie white signed with
the green bay packers okay as you're
saying that i did look it up and i was
alive but do i remember this absolutely
not because i was about one and a half
years old so i was little babies
going
eating dog biscuits but i i think what
you're saying is really interesting here
because if the browns can get somebody
of a jj watt caliber and then they pair
him opposite somebody like miles garrett
then i think you're right mike it really
does elevate what this browns defense
can be it elevates what the perception
of the browns defense can be around the
league as well because even though they
won a playoff game i don't think anybody
really thinks that the browns had an
elite defense last year and especially
when uh denzel award was out for them or
when miles garrett had to go out for a
couple games with covet that defense
just wasn't elite so they need more
pieces because they can be a really good
unit but if you have more guys like that
mike then i really think that they can
take that next step and not just win one
playoff game but maybe win multiple
playoff games
let's take a look at the browns
defenders who had multiple sacks in 2020
to give us an idea of where jj watt may
fit in with that team obviously miles
garrett is the man he had 12. olivier
vernon due to become a free agent with
nine sheldon richardson four and a half
adrian claiborne three and a half larry
ogun joby two and a half ogun joby had
his moments uh for the team
um
but uh uh more more so obviously miles
garrett the guy the man the player
around whom that defense is built and
when you have someone like that who
demands extra attention who's going to
ultimately be the the one you game plan
to stop
it creates an opening for j.j watt to be
you know the the guy that has an easier
path to the quarterback and i also think
the more pass rushers you have the
greater chance you have
frankly
to rotate in a healthy j.j watt and keep
him off the field more frequently so you
don't need him to go 100 of the snaps a
game because we know it's a rough and
tumble sport guys get injured especially
in the trenches like that and i said
this today i've got complete admiration
for a player who knows full well when he
gets his body to 100 percent he's going
to go out on that field and something's
going to break something's going to snap
something's going to tear he's going to
have to go back
work to get back to 100 and then go do
it again and it's this lather rinse
repeat that becomes a guy's career pain
surgery rehab
waiting frustration
and just to go do it again and put
yourself back at risk and uh with with a
a robust rotation miles great
opportunity for watt
to come out of a season without being as
banged up as we've seen him in the past
yeah and you know what this situation
kind of reminds me of is what the rams
have done with guys with aaron donald
you pair somebody with aaron donald and
you know aaron donald is the one that's
going to be
drawing the most attention from opposing
offenses so then other guys like
leonard floyd this past year he had a
great season there playing alongside
aaron donald dante fowler he's played
alongside aaron dalton for about a
season and a half and he got to cash in
with a pretty big payday there with the
atlanta falcons and now they may or may
not be regretting that a little bit clay
matthews also signed with the rams there
in 2019 in order to have that sort of
effect where it's like all right i can
go there and i can be effective because
teams aren't going to prepare for me
like they're going to prepare for him so
i think if you're jj watten you know
that you're also going to have miles
garrett alongside you on that defensive
line that can present you a lot of
opportunities for somebody who's getting
a little bit older but has still shown
that he can be effective in the right
spots and i think you're especially
right there mike with if he's in a good
rotation he doesn't have to be out there
all the time that could really make him
effective
last year the browns one of the teams
pursuing jedevian clowney they
ultimately didn't get him he had zero
sacks in eight games for the titans now
remember he's one of the guys who even
if he doesn't have sex he is a
significant
contributor in the
f up the play or as clay as campbell
calls it the fsu f stuff up
stat caleas campbell a master of that as
well so the lack of stats doesn't show
how disruptive clowning can be but what
can be clowning and what can get can get
disruption and what can get sex and what
can be a force and the other thing watt
can do he's just going to generate
excitement it may generate too much
excitement you know we saw the browns
miles in 2019 the bar was too high and
they ran around under it all year long
in 2020 the bar was too low they
exceeded it they got to the playoffs
they got to the final eight now what's
going to happen this year the bar is
going to be too high again and if they
get jj watt it's going to go even higher
and they're going to have a hard time
living up to the dramatically increased
expectations this year if they would get
jj watt even if they don't they're going
to have a hard time they get what the
expectations get even higher yeah they
get higher but i think if you're the
browns that's what you want you want to
be able to say can i live up to the high
expectations and frankly i think their
leadership right now is a much better
position than it ever was in 2019 when
they had freddy kitchens who had
ascended from running backs coach to
offensive coordinator to head coach in a
way that probably was too quick for
everybody involved and so i think with
kevin stefanski who showed that he's a
really good head coach coach of the year
i mean they won a playoff game even
though he was out with covet and i think
that speaks to just how effective he's
been as a leader in setting his team up
for success andrew berry i think has
done a really good job as the general
manager for that team as well over the
last year so i think that they're set up
to handle success mike a lot better than
they were in 2019 now for 2021.
we mentioned genevieve clowney going to
the titans last year it reunited him
with former texans defensive coordinator
mike rabel who's now the head coach of
the titans j.j watt
that same that same connection that same
link that same possibility that he goes
to the team that used to be the houston
oilers and is now the tennessee titans
john robinson gm of the team met with
reporters earlier today
here's robinson acknowledging that
there's been some discussion with j.j
watts camp
we've had some some contact you know
it's it's you know it's early in the
stages i think you know he's having uh
we obviously know his skill set and and
and what he's you know meant to meant to
the texans um haven't played against him
twice um the type of player he is uh so
we'll you know we'll just kind of see
how it goes like a lot of these guys
that you know that are coming available
over the next a few weeks you know see
kind of where you know their interest is
and um and then make a determination if
it's you know if it's if it's an avenue
that that hey we want to go down and and
are we a fit you know potentially for
some of these guys that become available
plenty of words ultimately saying
nothing and he's either keeping his
cards close to the vest or he's not
really interested he's just being polite
because he may have to play him again
why see something gratuitous that would
upset him like hey he's too old we don't
really want him he really doesn't fit he
really isn't all that good i didn't get
the impression that they're serious
unless they're being very very careful
not to drive up the market and not to
force the issue prematurely and have him
maybe sign with someone else who's got
more money and again knowing what you
will have under the cap is such a
critical part of this even if you have
cap space you need to know what the caps
going to be because you're going to have
a budget you're going to have an idea of
how much money you assign to this
position that position that position and
if you start spending more than you want
to more than you should
on a spot that j.j watt would fill on
the roster it's going to make it harder
for you to otherwise build out the team
so
you know this comes down to how patient
jj watts willing to be he's seriously
considering the browns because maybe the
browns are the only team that's
seriously making offers at this point
there isn't the land rush because of the
salary cap issues
i just would be surprised and amazed if
he ends up in cleveland i would be less
surprised if he ends up with the titans
both teams potential contenders you know
the hard part about this miles is
it's it's impossible to know with any
real certainty that that team you're
signing up for
has a clear shot at the super bowl too
many issues too many factors too many
variables go into a team season all you
can hope to sign with is a team that's
north of the basic line of contention
yeah and i think at least with these two
teams that we're talking about right now
with cleveland and with tennessee i
think that they're both above that sort
of line and i think that's why at least
at this point jj watt can say hey i'm
seriously considering signing with
cleveland and people can take it
seriously as we were sort of discussing
earlier but i think the interesting
thing about the titans is that they need
somebody to come in and help that
defense i mean this was not one of the
good defenses in the league across the
league they were the worst defense on
third down they allowed about 52
of third down conversions to be
completed that's not something that you
can sustain i think as a playoff
contender and somebody that actually
really wants to take it to the super
bowl and if you just continue to allow
teams to stay on the field and stay on
the field that's going to prevent you
from doing the things you want to do
offensively as well so the titans really
probably could use somebody like jj watt
to help improve that defensive unit but
i think like you said there was a lot of
just well you know we might be
interested and we've had discussions but
it could happen it could not happen it
depends if they were really that
interested i don't know if john robinson
would have been able to contain himself
more than he did you know what i'm
saying it just it didn't seem like it
was all that serious
well uh
he's gonna land somewhere we know that
there will be a market it's not the kind
of crazy land rush it would have been if
he'd been available five years ago but
this guy's a three-time defensive player
of the year he's got gas in the tank and
he brings leadership he brings
credibility he's going to sell 99
jerseys as long as he goes to a team
that doesn't have a guy who wears 99 or
hasn't retired 99 and jj what is going
to be
a force in 2021
i'm mike tarico and thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights from nbc
sports